Star Wars is one of the most popular and
influential stories ever told it began
with the wildly successful original
trilogy in the 70s and 80s and later
there was the prequel trilogy which most
people agree was not good there are also
heaps of books comics video games and TV
shows which form an expanded universe of
stories set within the same continuity
although they're no longer considered
Canon now that Disney has bought Star
Wars from George Lucas Disney is now
making a new trilogy set thirty years
after the original one so now it's a
good time to have a look at what
happened in the original three Star Wars
movies and what that might mean for the
new one in a new hope an evil empire
rules the galaxy and is at war with a
Rebel Alliance the Empire has massive
space ships and armies of stormtroopers
and of course the iconic Darth Vader it
also has the Death Star a huge armored
space station capable of destroying
whole planets rebel spies have stolen
the Empire's plans that the Death Star
and hope to use them to find a weakness
to destroy the weapon at the start of
the movie rebel leader Princess Leia is
taking these plans to rebels on Alderaan
but her ship is captured by the Empire
so she hides the plans and a message in
a robot or droid called r2d2 who along
with c-3po escapes to the desert planet
Tatooine that's where we meet our hero
Luke Skywalker a farm boy living with
his uncle and aunt and dreaming of
adventure Luke finds layer's message in
r2 and takes the droids to obi-wan
Kenobi one of the last remnants of an
order of lightsaber wielding space
Wizards called Jedi to use a mystical
energy field called the force to exert
magical power he says that Luke's father
was a Jedi who was betrayed and killed
by Darth Vader a Jedi who turned to the
dark side of the force when Luke finds
his aunt and uncle killed by the Empire
he agrees to go with obi-wan to deliver
Leia's plans to the rebels so they buy a
ride on the Millennium Falcon a
spaceship owned by the cynical
self-serving smuggler han Solo and his
hairy sidekick Chewbacca who talks like
this when I had to lay his home planet
Alderaan on the way over one starts to
Train Luke in the way of the force but
when they arrive older runs gone because
the Empire blew it up with the Death
Star because they're bad guys
the Falcon gets beamed into the Death
Star so Luke and Han and Chewie
rescue layer there are disguises and a
trash compactor and other shenanigans
and as they escape obi-wan is killed by
Darth Vader and as they leave the Falcon
is tracked by the Empire to the rebel
base on Yavin 4 so the Death Star comes
and there's a big space battle and Luke
uses the force and blows up the Death
Star it's a big victory for the rebels
and selfish Han Solo has a change of
heart in time to come help and get a
medal with Luke in the Empire Strikes
Back the rebels have established a new
base on the ice world Hoth Luke rides
around on a funny ice llama called a
tauntaun and is attacked by a Yeti
called a Whomper he almost dies in the
cold but is saved by han this is part of
Hans transformation from someone who
only cares for himself to someone
willing to risk his life for his friends
an imperial probe discovers the rebel
base so the Empire comes in force with
big stompy robots called a t-80s and
storm troopers led by Darth Vader so Han
and Leia flee Hoth in the Millennium
Falcon with Chewie and Threepio while
Luke heads to the swampy planet Dagobah
because he was told to by a force ghost
of obi-wan which is apparently a thing
han and Leia escape from Imperials
makeout because there's nothing like
some welding to get you in the mood and
escape from a freudian space worm thing
on Dagobah Luke meets a little green
Jedi Master called Yoda who trains Luke
in the way of the force
Yoda tells us about the dangers of the
dark side of the force which is
connected to negative emotions like
anger and fear and hate han and Leia
traveled to Cloud City to meet Hans old
friend Lando Calrissian who ends up
betraying them to the Empire Luke comes
to rescue his friends but when he gets
there harm has already been carbon
frozen into a living but inanimate block
and taken by Boba Fett who plans to sell
him to the crime lord Jabba the Hutt
Lando has a change of heart and helps
layer and ko escape from the Empire
meanwhile Luke dramatically confronts
Darth Vader who cuts off Luke's hand and
says I am Luke refuses to join the bad
guys and escapes to be rescued by Leia
Lando Chewie and the droids in Return of
the Jedi Leia Lando Chewie r2 and 3po
infiltrate the palace of Jabba the Hutt
who happens to be a gigantic slug they
revive Han from the Carbonite but get
caught by Jabba and Leia is enslaved in
an uncomfortable bikini Luke turns up
now a powerful and confident Jedi Knight
he bargains for Hans life and kills a
monster called a rank or but ends up
getting caught as well Jabba decides to
feed Luke and Han to a big tentacled
sand mouth called a Sarlacc but the
heroes escape Luke kicks Amar's harm
kills Boba accidentally and Leia kills
Jabba with the very chains that bound
her han and Leia meet back up with the
rebels and Luke returns to Dagobah where
Yoda dies the ghost of obi-wan tells
Luke that Lair is his twin sister which
makes this kiss kind of awkward
meanwhile the Empire is building a
second Death Star as the first one
worked so well and the rebels attack
with Lando leading a space battle while
on the forest moon of Endor han leads
some rebels and also some surprisingly
effective teddy bears called he walks
there's a speeder bike chase and some
teddy bear antics but in the end Luke
confronts Vader and meets his master the
Emperor they tried to get Luke to join
the dark side Luke struggles with his
emotions and cuts off Vader's hand but
ultimately rejects the dark side so the
Emperor tortures him with lightning and
in a final act of sacrificial Redemption
Vader saves his son by killing the
emperor and he has his helmet removed to
look upon his son before dying in Luke's
arms
the rebels destroy the second Death Star
han and Leia get together and everybody
celebrates the rebellion has beaten the
Empire so Star Wars has themes of
Destiny power love and redemption but at
the end of the day what it's really
about is a simple conflict between good
and evil with spaceships and lightsabers
and robots and aliens with funny names
it's not particularly deep stuff or
anything but it doesn't need to be it's
fun and we can probably expect something
very similar in the upcoming force
awakens indeed it still seems to be a
conflict between the remnants of the
Empire and the rebellion but that's not
to say it won't have it surprises
for example based on Luke's arc in the
original trilogy and his absence from
the force awakens trailers it's
speculated that Luke might have turned
to the dark side that he's a bad guy
in this new movie there are also lots of
cool theories about the original and
prequel series so comment below if you'd
like to see more Star Wars videos
explaining these ideas either way hope
you enjoyed this video many thanks to
all supporters on patreon including has
muffin Ruby goodnight pigeon pie as Ally
Podrick the [ __ ] Slayer
and Renly of house Baratheon first of
his name protector of the swag will be
holding a vote soon for the next game of
Thrones video topic which will be the
first video made by a full-time alt
shift X so thank you for that again and
see you next time